こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
たまごっちしってるかな？
僕が確か小学校くらいのときかな
それぐらいからたまごっちというものがあったんですけども
たまご型の液晶の画面がついてる
こういうちいさい
おもちゃがあって、
その中で
モンスターではないですね
お友達だね
モンスターではありませんよ
お友達
たまごっちという名前のね
お友達をね育てる
こういう小さい
ゲームがあったんですよ
子供のころはなんか
育てるのが好きだったから
たまごっちをねチョイチョイチョイ
っとやってた覚えがあるんですけども
そのたまごっちが！！
この現代において
すっげえ進化してます
はいこちら
最新型のたまっごち
でございます
全８色あります
お寿司のたまごみたいな髪型してる
わけなんですけども
あ、俺はたまごっちじゃねえよ？
おすしっちみたいなね
お～こんなかんじです
もうなんか進化しすぎててやばいんですけど
見た目がもうねすごい
なんかシンプルなデザインになりますね
ボタン３つは変わってないです
メタリックなこの
フレームがすごいかっこいいです
たまごっちの魅力はですね
成長してきます
ちゃんとたまごっちが
たまごからはじまって
幼児期
反抗期
フレンド期
さらに今回こちらにこせーて期という新しい
成長がみられるらしいです
名前と性別・誕生日
年齢・星座・趣味
将来の夢・好きな食べ物・特技・好きな人
お腹が空いたら食べ物をあげて
コミニケーションをとり
トイレをして
お風呂に入り
部屋が汚れたら掃除して
お出かけして
ゲームして
公園で遊んで
学校に行き
お見合いもできるのね
お見合いをして
結婚して
しっかりたまごっちを育てるわけなんですけども
俺がたまごっちを最後に育てたのは
小学校のときくらい
今の俺は小学生では
ない
そうだろ
俺はもう大人だ
この大人になったはじめ
いまならきっと
そう、天才の俺ならさらに
多くのたまごっちをいっきに
いっきに！！
育てられると思ったわけなんだ
今回はこのたまごっち１個
だけを育てるわけじゃなく
こちら！
もうたまごっちを育てるプロなんで
この天才はじめにかかると
たまごっち１００匹
全員しっかり育てあげて
お見合いできる・結婚できる
年齢まで育てます
正直できるかわかんな．．
あーーできるよ
出来ますよ！
ただあの未知の領域なんで
ちょっと何が起きるか自分でもよくわかんない
バナナいちご的な？
俺は乙女か！
お、こっちもいいね
乙女か！
おれは乙女か！
はい　こういう感じで
いろんな色のたまごっちを
作ることが出来ます
はい　というわけで個性的なたまごっちが
何個か出来たところで
ここからです！！
まずは電池を入れていきましょう
こいつが第一号です
こいつからすべてが始まるわけですよ
一応電池はいれたんですけどまだ始まってません
とりあえず１００個全部電池を入れていきましょう
あっ！えっ！あああ
待て待てえ？え？え？
やばいやばいやばい待って！
ちょっとお前は？
この子はどうして始まんなかった？
あっ逆だった
あ、ほら　逆だった
電池逆だった
はい　ラスト１個終わりました
ここからだ
この後たまごっちの日付と時間の設定をします
夕方の６時
誕生日は２月の１４日ですね
これで決定ですね　はい　これ決定
たまごがきました
これでたまごが孵化するのを待つのかな
たまごが超はねてる
おおー！！
あらー
こんにちは　おめでとう的なね
はじめ　はいありがとうございます
今おなかがすごい空いてる状態ですね
めすか　女の子でしたね
とりあえずご飯を食べさせなきゃ
はいというわけでこんなかんじでございますね
おめでとう
今名前入力してるからね
ちょっと待ってね名前入力してるからね
ご飯はあとで食べさせる
あれ？これ風邪引いてんじゃん
ちょ　風邪引いてる
１人目がもうちょっと病気っぽくなってます
待って待って治さなきゃ
待って待って今．．
待っててねー
待ってね
これやべーぞ
やべーぞこれ
えー
みんな産まれてきてくれてありがとう！！
ただこの子たち、、うわ！！やばい
みんな病気になってんじゃん
皆具合悪そうにしてるんですよ今
８割ぐらい具合悪そうにしてます
あ！労わるだ！労われば直る
ここらへんちょっと皆病気をとりあえず治していきたいと
思ってます
寝てる子はok
なんか寝てる子も出てきましたね
だめだちょっと間に合ってないですね
厳しいぞこれは
なにが起きてる？
お！お！
成長した
だれ？
え？なにこの白いの
りおねっちって名前らしいですね
みんな進化できるととてもいいな
がんばれー
今度なんか天丼みたい
天丼君かな
あ、　寝ながら病気になっちゃた
あ、さっきと同じだ
クリオネ
いま反抗期ですね
いま皆反抗期に入りだします
皆体調悪くも進化しだしてるぞ
おなかは？大丈夫？
あ、お腹空いてるね
ご飯食べましょう
君も進化するのね
オッケー！オッケー！
ちょっと待ってね
きみはとりあえず病気を治そう
あ！だれか進化した
きみはもうごはんはお腹いっぱいね
めっちゃ進化フィーバーじゃん今
急に騒がしくなって
シーンと今静まりました
はい今　夜なのでなんかみんな寝だしましたね
これが明日の朝になると
怖いんだよなー
とりあえず皆寝てるということで
初日はなんとか乗り切ったのじゃないでしょうか
具合悪い状態で寝てる子達もいたんで
その子達明日の朝に何とか治せればと思っております
おやすみなさい
はいおはようございます
朝です
はい何人かもう朝起きてきてます
おはよう
はじはって言ってますね
具合が悪いままねちゃた子もいるんで
そいつらのケアをまずしていきたいと思ってます
起きてる子探しからはじまるね
みんなが起きる前に今起きてるやつらだけでも
とりあえずしっかり体調を整えておこう
だいぶ皆元気になってきましたね
結構皆元気になってきたんですけども
急にそのわぁっと起きられると
お父さんも参っちゃうからね
みんなが寝てる間僕はね今早起きしたお友達と遊んじゃうぞ
あ！あ！やばい
やばい！
おれの天丼っちと天丼っちが一緒に写真撮ってる
なにしろ友達が１００人いるわけだから
お前たち遊び放題だぞ
君たち一生のうちに全員に会うことはできないかもしれないね
おはよう
誰？
誰起きた？
え？やばい
起きはじめた
結構皆起き始めてきたんですけども
体調がみんな最悪でございます
これで日中はお世話してくれる感じなのかな
おはよう
みんな会社に行ったり　学校に行ったり
１日中たまごっちを育てる暇がないと思うんですよ
１００人のたまシッターに来てもらいましょう
たまシッター呼べない子がたまにいるんだけど
たまシッター呼べないときがある
愛情度が０のときに預けられないということか
やばい
何人か愛情が０になってる人たちがいて
その子たちはもうたまシッター預けることも
できないっぽいです
一刻を争うじゃんじゃあ
愛情度が皆ないぞ
愛情が
やばい
預けられない
結果から申し上げますと
１００匹育ててみたは無理でした
すいませんでした
はい　こういう感じで
ほとんどのたまごっちは手紙を残して
家出してしまいました
ここの１０人だけは僕のそばにいてくれてます
後の90個は.....（はじめの泣き声）
ああーでも物理的に無理だな
すいません物理的に無理です
頑張って育てられるのは１０匹くらいだと
僕は感じました
もうね手が回らない
皆もうぼくのことがいやになって
家出しちゃったんですけども
今回家出してしまった９０個
のたまごっちは皆さんにプレゼントしようと思います
他の９０匹は他の子達に幸せにしてもらってほしい
動画の概要欄から応募ホーム
があるのでそちらからぜひたまごっち
プレゼント応募してください
９０名様でございます
あのーほんとに１００匹はまじで忙しかったです
もう今までで一番忙しかったっていっても
過言ではないくらい大変だったんですけども
たまごっちがすごいかわいくてすごい
愛着が湧いちゃって
何とかしよう何とかしようと思って
何とか出来ませんでした
出来ればちゃんと皆フレンド期までそだてたかったんですけど
まぁちょっと数が多すぎたかな
お見合いとか結婚までさせたかったけどなー
はいというわけでたまごっち4uの育て方や
お得な情報を知りたい人は
たまごっちのyoutubeチャンネル
があります
たまごっちｔｖ
こちらの方をぜひ見てみてください
こちらも動画の説明欄からURLがあります
非常にほんとに大変だったけどたまごっちかわいかった
僕は１匹でいいかな